I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你录制了这档终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。
We're The Office, ladies. Hi, Angela. Hey, Jenna. How's it going? It's going good. Are you ready to destroy a small family business today? Oh, Prince Family Paper. The Prince Family? They're the sweetest family.
我们就是办公室女郎。嗨，安吉拉。嘿，珍娜。最近怎么样？挺好的。你准备好今天毁掉一家小型家族企业了吗？哦，普林斯家族纸业。普林斯家族？他们是最善良的一家人。
Well, we're going to take them down. I guess we are. So awful and cringy. Oh, there's a lot of cringe in this one. There sure is. Guys, it's season five, episode 13, Prince Family Paper, written by B.J. Novak and directed by Assad Kalada. Here's your summary.
好吧，我们要把他们拉下马。我想是的。真是太糟糕、太尴尬了。哦，这一集里有很多尴尬的场面。确实有很多。伙计们，这是第五季第13集，《普林斯家族纸业》，由B·J·诺瓦克编剧，阿萨德·卡拉达执导。以下是本集摘要。
Oh. David Wallace calls Michael Scott on the phone. It's so funny to me. I'm so sorry to interrupt your summary that I acted surprised. That I was going to read a summary? Yeah, you're like, here's a summary. I went, oh. Oh.
哦。大卫·华莱士给迈克尔·斯科特打电话。我觉得这太搞笑了。我很抱歉打断了你装作很惊讶的摘要。我正准备读摘要？对，你当时说，这里是摘要。然后我来了个，哦。哦。
Well, look, his sassy pants has a summary. She has one every weekend. Just expect it. OK, go. David Wallace calls Michael Scott on the phone. He wants to get his help gathering intel on a rival paper company called Prince Family Paper. Michael takes Dwight along as his backup.
好吧，你看，这个傲娇鬼居然有摘要。她每周末都有。习惯就好。好了，开始。大卫·华莱士给迈克尔·斯科特打电话。他想让迈克尔帮忙收集一家名为普林斯家族纸业的竞争对手公司的情报。迈克尔带着德怀特作为后援。
And meanwhile, the gang debate whether or not Hillary Swank qualifies as hot. Yep. Yep. All right. I have to say one thing. I just got to get this out. Get it out.
与此同时，大家在争论希拉里·斯万克到底算不算性感。没错。没错。好吧。我得说一件事。我必须把它一吐为快。说出来吧。
There used to be a magazine. I don't know which one. You know who you are. They would do this thing. Who wore it best? Oh, yeah. They would put two people side by side in like the same dress or a skirt or pants.
以前有一本杂志。我不知道是哪一本。你们自己心里清楚。他们会做一个栏目。谁穿得最好？哦，对。他们会把两个人并排放在一起，穿着同样的裙子、半身裙或裤子。
And there was always one person that wore it best. Right. And they would have a percentage. Like people voted. Yeah, people voted. And you might have worn it best because you were tall and not 5'1". OK.
总有一个人穿得最好。对。然后他们会给出一个百分比。就像人们投票那样。对，人们投票。也许你穿得最好，因为你个子高，而且不是5英尺1英寸。好吧。
OK. And maybe you knew to wear the right kind of heels and someone else wore flip flops with it. OK. I don't know. Right. I'm just saying to that magazine and people that like to compare who wore it best or who's hotter, who's not,
好吧。也许你知道穿对高跟鞋，而另一个人却穿着人字拖。好吧。我不知道。对。我只想对那本杂志和那些喜欢比较谁穿得最好，或者谁更性感、谁不性感的人说，
I say suck it. Thank you, Angela. That's all I'm going to say. Well, that was clearly a general comment. Nothing based on personal experience, I can tell. I'll have you know I've also been the subject of a who wore it best. So I feel that.
去你的吧。谢谢你，安吉拉。这就是我想说的。好吧，这显然是一个普遍的评论。我可以看出，这绝对不是基于个人经验。我要告诉你，我也曾是“谁穿得最好”的主角。所以我感同身受。
Yeah. You know what? You all wear it best. We all wear it how we wear it. Yeah. OK. That's how I wore it. That's my body.
是啊。你知道吗？你们每个人都穿得最好。我们都按照自己的方式穿。对。好吧。这就是我的穿衣风格。这就是我的身材。
That's how my body wears stuff. How about who wore it? Me. I wore it. Yeah. 100% to me. Yeah. For wearing it.
这就是我的身材穿衣服的方式。至于谁穿得最好？我。我穿的。是的。百分之百是我。是的。因为是我穿的。
And you know what? I got dressed this morning. You're welcome. As you can tell, this episode might have triggered something for us. As you can tell, two gals are sitting here. Not super appreciating debates on who's hotter, who's not.
而且你知道吗？我今天早上穿好衣服了。不客气。如你所见，这一集可能触动了我们的一些神经。如你所见，两个大姐们正坐在这里。对谁更性感、谁不性感的辩论实在提不起什么兴趣。
Yeah. Kevin has a lot of thoughts about it. This might be the most Kevin ever spoke in a whole episode. Yes. I think this is his most line count ever. Possibly. Well, I think we should get to some fast facts.
对。凯文对此有很多想法。这可能是凯文在一整集里说话最多的一次了。是的。我认为这是他台词最多的一次。有可能。好吧，我觉得我们该进入快讯环节了。
I agree. Here we go. Fast fact number one, new director alert. Yeah. Assad Kalata. Yes. So our line producer, Randy Cordray, had worked with Assad before, and he told us that Assad was actually
我同意。我们开始吧。快讯一号，新导演警报。是的。阿萨德·卡拉达。是的。我们的制片主任兰迪·科德雷以前和阿萨德合作过，他告诉我们，阿萨德其实
originally supposed to direct an episode in season four. But that season got cut because of the writer strike. Oh. And so they slotted him for season five instead. So we could have almost gotten to work with this man earlier. And I tell you what, he is a delight. You guys, he's like television legend. He's directed everything.
原本应该在第四季导演一集的。但由于编剧罢工，那一季被砍掉了。哦。所以他们把他安排到了第五季。所以我们差点就能早点和这位男士合作了。我告诉你，他太招人喜欢了。伙计们，他就像电视界的传奇。他执导过所有东西。
Yes. He has directed 77 episodes of the facts of life and 117 episodes of who's the boss. I know who's the boss. If your name is Angela, you know who's the boss. What? So the female leads characters named Angela. You guys, this show was out in the 90s.
是的。他执导过77集《妙管家》和117集《谁是老板》。我知道《谁是老板》。如果你叫安吉拉，你就知道《谁是老板》。什么？所以女主角的名字叫安吉拉。伙计们，这部剧是90年代播出的。
I was in college in the 90s. I cannot even tell you how many people left this on my answering machine. Angela. I had that on my voicemail. I would say on a monthly basis. That's crazy. Let me finish telling you a little bit about Assad.
我90年代还在上大学。我甚至无法告诉你有多少人在我的答录机里留言。安吉拉。我的语音信箱里有这个。我差不多每个月都会听到。太疯狂了。让我接着讲一点关于阿萨德的事。
We loved working with him. I found an interview he did where he said this, which I thought was so great. He said that the most essential thing for making a successful comedy is casting. He said that is because, quote, you cannot make the actor be funny. Comedy is all about rhythm, timing, pace and energy.
我们很喜欢和他合作。我找到了一篇他做过的采访，他在里面说了这样一句话，我觉得太棒了。他说制作一部成功喜剧最关键的东西是选角。他说这是因为，引述他的话，“你无法让演员变得搞笑。喜剧全靠节奏、时机、步伐和活力。”
I agree. I thought that was so well said. Yeah. All right. Fast fact number two. We got a lot of fan questions about the hot or not storyline. This one comes from Joe S. Who asked what inspired the
我同意。我觉得这话太精辟了。是的。好的。快讯二号。我们收到了很多关于性感与否这条故事线的粉丝提问。这个问题来自乔·S。他问是什么激发了
subplot of the debate about whether or not Hillary Swank was hot or not? Was it a magazine that said who were at best? It wasn't. It wasn't. BJ Novak did an interview with Indie Week and he said that he was on a flight and two of the in-flight movies were PS I Love You and The Great Debaters.
关于希拉里·斯万克性感与否的辩论这一支线剧情的灵感？是因为一本杂志评选谁穿得最好吗？并不是。并不是。B·J·诺瓦克接受《印第周刊》采访时说，他当时在飞机上，机上电影里有两部是《P.S. 我爱你》和《激辩风云》。
They were both Hillary Swank movies. He was tasked with coming up with a B-plot for an episode and he thought, quote, why not debate about Hillary Swank? And then he decided that the characters could debate whether or not she is attractive. We got more questions from Amy J. and Rohit R. How does Hillary Swank feel about this episode?
这两部都是希拉里·斯万克的电影。他当时的任务是为一集构思B线剧情，他想，引用他的话，“为什么不辩论一下希拉里·斯万克呢？”然后他决定让角色们辩论她到底有没有吸引力。我们收到了来自艾米·J.和罗希特·R.的更多问题。希拉里·斯万克对这一集有什么感觉？
Oh, wow. Good question. Very good question. Well, she did an interview with Time Magazine shortly after this episode came out. She was asked if she had seen the episode and she said this, I'm not a big television watcher, but definitely everyone made me aware of it.
哦，哇。好问题。非常好的问题。嗯，这一集播出后不久，她接受了《时代》周刊的采访。当被问及她是否看过这一集时，她说了这样的话：我不怎么看电视，但绝对每个人都让我知道了这件事。
Oh, geez. I think it's flattering anytime someone mentions you, but I don't think of myself in terms of that, meaning like she doesn't lead with if she's hot or not. Right. Later on in the interview, she was asked about women in Hollywood in general and she replied, there is so much put on the way we look,
哦，天哪。我觉得只要有人提到你，无论何时都是一种恭维，但我不会从那个角度来想自己，意思是她不会把重点放在自己性感与否上。没错。采访后来，当被问及好莱坞女性的总体情况时，她回答说，人们对我们的外表寄予了太多期望，
which is interesting going back to your office question. Are you hot or are you not? It really does a disservice because there's so much more to life than looking a certain way. We love you, Hillary. Hillary. Well said. Well said.
这很有趣，回到了你们关于办公室的问题。你性感吗？还是你不性感？这真的帮了倒忙，因为生活中除了看起来怎么样之外，还有很多更重要的事。我们爱你，希拉里。希拉里。说得好。说得好。
Fast fact number three, Hillary Swank is a badass. Would you like to hear a little about her? Yes. All right. She was born in Lincoln, Nebraska. She competed in the Junior Olympics and the Washington state championships in swimming and she ranked fifth in state in all around gymnastics.
快讯三号，希拉里·斯万克是个女汉子。你想听听关于她的一些事吗？好啊。好的。她出生于内布拉斯加州林肯市。她曾参加过青少年奥运会和华盛顿州游泳锦标赛，并且在全能体操项目中排名全州第五。
Wow. All around gymnastics. That's the one where you have to do all the things. You do everything. You do all the things. She ranked fifth in the state. Okay. Her parents separated when she was a teenager
哇。全能体操。就是那种你必须完成所有项目的比赛。你什么都要做。你什么项目都做。她在州里排名第五。好吧。她十几岁时父母离异了，
and she really wanted to be an actress. So her mom moved with her to Los Angeles when she was 16 years old. And she's spoken a lot about this. They did not have a lot of money for a while and they lived out of their car. They did eventually find a place to live. She enrolled in school and then when she was 20,
而她非常想成为一名演员。所以当她16岁时，她妈妈带着她搬到了洛杉矶。她公开谈论过很多次这件事。有一段时间他们没有多少钱，只能住在车里。后来他们终于找到了住处。她去上学了，当她20岁时，
so four years after she moved to LA, she landed the starring role in the next karate kid. Julie Pierce. Yeah. Yeah. You know all about this, Ange. I do because you guys, I got really into Cobra Kai this past year.
也就是她搬到洛杉矶四年后，她拿到了《新龙威小子》的主角。朱莉·皮尔斯。对。对。安吉，你对这些了如指掌。我确实知道，因为伙计们，我过去这一年超级迷恋《眼镜蛇道馆》。
Are you guys watching Cobra Kai? It's so good. I'm not watching it. Should I be watching it? I am loving it. It's also just major, like 80s nostalgia. It's so good. Is this something I can watch with my kids?
你们在看《眼镜蛇道馆》吗？太棒了。我没看。我应该看吗？我太喜欢了。它也充满了强烈的80年代怀旧情怀。太棒了。这是我可以和孩子们一起看的剧吗？
Or is it more adulty? I've heard it's a little bit skews older. It's skews older than my kids. Yes. I'm not watching it with my kids. Oh, this is your time. Yeah. Okay.
还是说它更偏向成人向？我听说它的受众年龄偏大一点。它的受众比我的孩子大。是的。我没有和孩子们一起看。哦，这是你的专属时间。是的。好吧。
Josh and I watch it together. I'm sure there's, you know, teenagers that watch it, but Josh and I watch it together. So basically it's sort of picking up where they are now, right? Mm-hmm. With the two lead guys. And John Hurwitz, who's the co-creator, they reached out to me to play one of the kids' mom.
乔希和我一起看。我敢肯定，你知道的，也有青少年在看，但乔希和我是一起看的。所以基本上它就像是从他们现在的状态接着演，对吧？嗯哼。围绕着那两个男主角。而联合创作者乔恩·赫维茨，他们联系了我，让我去扮演其中一个孩子的妈妈。
What? Yes. And I wanted to do it, but it was filming in Atlanta, and you basically have to go to Atlanta for a while, and I couldn't do that. I couldn't be away from my kids for that long. Yeah. You know, it wasn't like an in and out.
什么？是的。我想演，但它是在亚特兰大拍摄的，你基本上得去亚特兰大待上一段时间，而我做不到。我不能离开我的孩子那么久。是的。你知道的，这不是那种来去匆匆的活儿。
But listen, John Hurwitz, if you ever moved to Los Angeles, if you ever decide to film here, I am there. People have been speculating, will Julie come back? Because they're bringing all the characters back. And this is what John Hurwitz said in an interview. They discussed the possibility of bringing Julie Pierce on the show. He said, in our writer's room, we speak about literally every character that has appeared
但是听着，乔恩·赫维茨，如果你以后搬到洛杉矶来，如果你决定在这里拍摄，我随时奉陪。人们一直在猜测，朱莉会回来吗？因为他们把所有的角色都带回来了。乔恩·赫维茨在采访中是这样说的。他们讨论了让朱莉·皮尔斯回归剧中的可能性。他说，在我们的编剧室里，我们讨论了每一个出现在
in the Miyagi verse. They call it the Miyagi verse. So it's obvious we've spoken about Julie Pierce as to whether or not she'll return to the series. That's something you'll just have to wait to find out. Ooh. I'm here for it, John. Bring her back.
宫城宇宙中的角色。他们管这叫宫城宇宙。所以很明显，我们讨论过朱莉·皮尔斯是否会回归剧集。至于她会不会回来，你只能拭目以待了。噢。我支持你，乔恩。把她带回来吧。
Also, a little bit of office crossover. Jen Salata has directed several episodes of Cobra Kai. Wow. Yeah. I would love it if Hillary's like, Hillary, go back. Go do a guest star on Cobra Kai. It'd be so good.
还有，一点办公室联动。詹·萨拉塔导演了好几集《眼镜蛇道馆》。哇。是的。如果希拉里能说，希拉里，回去吧。去客串一集《眼镜蛇道馆》吧。那就太棒了。
And then maybe there's like some little bit you could do in her episode. Yes, Hillary, maybe I could be your best friend. This is it. And then I could go just for a week, John, just like four days. Yeah. Okay.
然后也许你可以在她的那一集里做一点小客串。是的，希拉里，也许我可以成为你的好朋友。就是这样。然后我就可以去一周，乔恩，就去四天。好的。
There, we worked it out. Jen Salata. Jen Salata directed. Make it happen. Make it happen. Well, Hillary Sink was 20 years old when she was a next Karate Kid. When she was 25 years old,
好了，我们谈妥了。詹·萨拉塔。詹·萨拉塔导演的。让它发生吧。让它发生吧。好吧，希拉里·斯万克拍《新龙威小子》时20岁。在她25岁时，
she did the lead role in Boys Don't Cry. Wow. And she won an Oscar. She is one of the youngest women to ever win an Oscar. She also won an Oscar for her lead role in Million Dollar Baby. That movie destroyed me. Those movies. I mean, they're, ugh.
她主演了《男孩不哭》。哇。她赢得了一座奥斯卡奖。她是赢得奥斯卡奖最年轻的女性之一。她还凭借在《百万美元宝贝》中的主演角色赢得了一座奥斯卡奖。那部电影把我击垮了。那些电影。我是说，它们，呃。
There are only 12 other actresses who have won two or more lead actress Oscars. Those are both lead actress Oscars. So she's in a very impressive club there. She sure is. So that's Hillary Swank, y'all. Well, Hillary, we are here for you. We should take a break and we come back.
只有其他12位女演员曾赢得过两座或更多最佳女主角奥斯卡奖。这两次都是最佳女主角奥斯卡奖。所以她加入了一个非常令人印象深刻的俱乐部。她确实加入了。所以这就是希拉里·斯万克，各位。好吧，希拉里，我们支持你。我们该休息一下，回来之后，
There is a classic Jim Prink. This episode opens with everyone just working at their desks. We're just working. Just a normal day. No biggie. But then Dwight discovers a red wire that's plugged into his computer. No other computers have red wires.
有一个经典的吉姆式恶作剧。这一集以每个人都在办公桌前工作开场。我们只是在工作。普普通通的一天。没什么大不了的。但接着德怀特发现有一根红色的电线插在他的电脑上。没有其他电脑有红色的电线。
What is it? Yeah, it's a new wire. It's never been there before. Yeah. Well, he starts tearing at this wire. Yeah, he wants to know where it's coming from. Yeah. In the script, it says, Dwight pulls the wire off the floor
这是什么？是的，这是一根新电线。以前从来没有过。是的。好吧，他开始扯这根电线。是的，他想知道它是从哪来的。是的。剧本上写着，德怀特把电线从地板上拉起来，
and follows it to the wall. It goes over a door frame, under Phyllis's desk, and Dwight crawls under Phyllis's desk. Oh, we did it a little differently. We did it a little differently. First of all, you can't crawl through Phyllis's desk because there was like a backstop, right? Yeah.
顺着它找到墙壁。它穿过一个门框，在菲莉丝的桌子底下，然后德怀特爬到了菲莉丝的桌子底下。哦，我们拍得稍微有点不同。我们拍得稍微有点不同。首先，你没法爬过菲莉丝的桌子，因为那里有个挡板，对吧？是的。
It doesn't go all the way through to Stanley's desk. And in the script, Phyllis says, Dwight, get out of there. And that's pretty much in the episode. And then Dwight would have said, shush, shush, shush. But I think Rain improvised, shut up, Phyllis. So Dwight's going to follow this wire into the hall. Yeah, all the way outside and up a telephone pole, which we can see over Jim's shoulder in Jim's talking head.
它没法一路通到斯坦利的桌子底下。在剧本里，菲莉丝说，德怀特，从那儿出来。剧集里差不多也是这样。然后德怀特本该说，嘘，嘘，嘘。但我觉得雷因即兴发挥说的是，闭嘴，菲莉丝。所以德怀特顺着这根电线走进了大厅。是的，一路走到外面，爬上了一根电话亭的电线杆，我们在吉姆的单人镜头里可以透过吉姆的肩膀看到它。
Right. And it is a real telephone pole. It's a real telephone pole. Jim says he got 500 feet of red wire at a flea market for 20 bucks. How long did this take him? Jim has a lot of extra time. He gets to work so early. I feel like Pam is like, you know what,
没错。而且那是一根真正的电话杆。那是根真正的电话杆。吉姆说他在跳蚤市场花20块钱买了几百英尺红色的电线。这花了多长时间？吉姆有太多多余的时间了。他上班太早了。我觉得帕姆会想，你知道吗，
I know we were going to carpool, but you've got that Dwight prank, and you've got to go at three in the morning, and I'm going to sleep in. Yeah. Like, what's the real life side of that? I reached out to Randy to find out how we did this stunt of Rain up on this telephone pole.
我知道我们要拼车，但你有个德怀特的恶作剧要搞，你得凌晨三点去，我要睡懒觉了。是的。就像，现实生活中那是什么样的？我联系了兰迪，想了解我们是怎么拍雷因爬上这根电话杆这个特技的。
Right, he can't climb a real telephone pole. That's not safe. No, because what he told me was that the pole over Jim's shoulder really is an actual working utility pole that's embedded in our sidewalk, you know, right out there. Folks, don't go climb it for a photo. Don't climb it. You can get electrocuted.
对，他不可能爬一根真正的电话杆。那不安全。对，因为他告诉我说，吉姆肩膀后面的那根杆子实际上是一根真正正常使用的公用电线杆，就嵌在我们的街边人行道上，你知道的，就在外面。各位，千万别为了拍照去爬它。别爬。你会触电的。
Yeah, it carried high voltage electricity. They couldn't even have a stunt person dressed as Dwight climb that pole. Yeah. So our production designer Michael Gallenberg and his construction team rented a matching utility pole. You can do that, I guess. No. Where is that?
是的，上面带着高压电。他们甚至不能让一个穿着德怀特衣服的特技替身去爬那根杆子。是的。所以我们的美术指导迈克尔·盖伦伯格和他的施工团队租了一根一模一样的公用电线杆。我想这也是可以租到的。不对。那是去哪租的？
I mean, seriously, how do they know these things? This is the crazy part of Hollywood magic. Oh, you know what I'm going to do today? I'm going to rent a fake telephone pole. Yeah. That's huge. Huge. Well, they put it up in our parking lot between the two sound stages,
我是说，真的，他们怎么知道这些事情的？这就是好莱坞魔法疯狂的地方。哦，你知道我今天要干嘛吗？我要去租一根假的电话杆。是的。太夸张了。太夸张了。好吧，他们把它竖在我们的停车场里，就在两个摄影棚之间，
and they put like a green padded platform around it. In case you fell? Yep. And they put up a big green screen behind the whole thing. And then they brought rain out along with like a stunt coordinator and a safety officer, and they had rain climb up. It was only a few feet that he had to climb. And then in post-production, they had their visual effects team
他们还在周围铺了一个绿色的软垫平台。万一你掉下来？是的。他们还在整个装置后面支起了一个巨大的绿幕。然后他们把雷因带出来，还有特技统筹和安全官员，让雷因爬上去。他其实只需要爬几英尺高。然后在后期制作中，他们让视觉特效团队
digitally add rain to the real pole over Jim's shoulder. They superimposed like one pole onto the other. Yes. Got it. Even though rain was really only a little bit off the ground, they could like hike it up so it looked like he was like halfway up the pole. Way up there. Yeah.
用数字技术把雷因加到了吉姆肩膀后面那根真正的电线杆上。他们把一根杆子的影像叠加到了另一根上。是的。明白了。尽管雷因实际上离地面只有一点点高，但他们可以把他调高，看起来就像他爬到了杆子的一半高度。高高在上。是的。
That's movie magic, folks. That is some good movie magic. But here's the thing that gets me about that. That's like real special effects, kind of like stunty stuff for our little TV show about a paper company. Like I never really thought hard about how much work it took to do that gag until we went to break it down. Yeah.
这就是电影的魔法，各位。这真是一些很棒的电影魔法。但关于这一点，最让我不解的是。对于我们这个关于一家纸业公司的情景喜剧小节目来说，这就像是真正的特效，有点像特技。直到我们开始拆解这一集之前，我从来没有认真想过完成那个恶作剧需要付出多少工作。是的。
Right? Like it's such a quick little blip. And you're like, that was like two weeks of figuring that out. Of prep. Yeah. I feel like every week we are learning how much Michael Gallenberg, Kyle Alexander, Phil Shea, our wardrobe department, set designers, how they all made these little moments happen and made it seamless.
对吧？就像是一个超级快的小片段。而你会想，那是花了两个星期才搞定的。在做前期准备。是的。我觉得每周我们都在了解迈克尔·盖伦伯格、凯尔·亚历山大、菲尔·谢伊、我们的服装部门、布景设计师，他们是如何让所有这些小瞬间发生并做到天衣无缝的。
Yeah. I know, so much work goes into these little things. It's amazing. The fruit fly wrangler. We had to know they're like mating cycle. Craziness. It's crazy. Well, that was the cold open.
是的。我知道，这些小事情背后付出了太多的工作。太神奇了。果蝇驯养员。我们得了解它们的交配周期。太疯狂了。简直疯狂。好吧，那是片头冷笑剧。
Now we start this episode. Michael's in his office. He's on the phone with David Wallace. I feel like David's really playing Michael here because he dangles out that regional supervisor job. He's like, you know, I still haven't filled that slot yet. And Michael's like, oh, and then he asked Michael to go do this thing. Yeah.
现在我们开始这一集。迈克尔在他的办公室里。他在和大卫·华莱士通电话。我觉得大卫在这里真的在拿捏迈克尔，因为他抛出了那个大区主管的职位诱饵。他说，你知道的，我还没填满那个空缺呢。然后迈克尔就，哦，接着他让迈克尔去做这件事。是的。
He's like a spy on this tiny little paper company. I know. To do some field work. Michael's so excited. Oh, yeah. During this scene, I was really struck by the toys on Michael's desk because they would rotate them. They would, you guys.
他就像去一家极其微小的纸业公司当间谍。我懂。去做点外勤。迈克尔太兴奋了。哦，是的。在这场戏中，我真的被迈克尔桌子上的玩具吸引住了，因为他们会轮流更换它们。他们真的会，伙计们。
Every once in a while, there would be some new toys. Here's what was on his desk. A Rubik's Cube. Not finished. Mm-hmm. A tiny pool table. Yes. A colorful plastic expanding ball thingy.
每隔一段时间，就会出现一些新玩具。以下是当时他桌子上的东西。一个魔方。没拼完。嗯哼。一张迷你台球桌。是的。一个彩色的塑料伸缩球状物。
You know that thingy? Yeah, yeah. That's a staple. Yes. And also the wind-up teeth. Those are always there. Yeah. But the pool table had moved.
你知道那个小玩意吗？对，对。那是常备道具。是的。还有上发条的假牙。那些一直都在。是的。但是台球桌被移位了。
So he's clearly played it recently. And it's on top of all the stuff in his inbox. He can't get to anything in his inbox. It's not important. The pool table is number one of things to do. Yeah. Oh, make me laugh. A miniature pool table in his inbox
所以他显然最近玩过了。而且它压在他收件箱里的所有东西上面。他什么都拿不到收件箱里的东西。那不重要。台球桌才是待办事项的第一位。是的。哦，逗死我了。收件箱里放个微型台球桌，
says everything you need to know about Michael Scott's work ethic. That's right. Emily and Phyllis are going to start having this conversation about whether or not they think Hillary's swank is hot. And the rest of the gang gets involved. I feel like these kind of moments happen in small offices. You sort of start to debate things. Like you pick a soccer team during the playoffs
这说明了关于迈克尔·斯科特职业道德的一切。没错。埃米莉和菲莉丝开始讨论她们是否觉得希拉里·斯万克性感。然后其他人也加入了进来。我觉得这种时刻经常在小型办公室里发生。你们开始争论各种事情。就像在季后赛期间挑选一支足球队，
and people debate about the players and it can become a whole thing. And it's just a way to fill the boredom. Oh, for sure. I have a bone to pick with Jim. Why is that? At three minutes, 18 seconds, I titled this moment, what the hell, Jim?
人们会争论球员，这最后会变成一件大事。这只是打发无聊的一种方式。哦，肯定的。我对吉姆有点意见。为什么这么说？在3分18秒的时候，我给这个时刻取名为：吉姆，你搞什么鬼？
What is the moment? Jim suggests they put it to a vote in the bullpen. Angela says she isn't voting. And Jim says nobody cares. Oh. What the hell, Jim? That's some Jim sass. Jim sass.
是什么时刻？吉姆建议大家在办公区举手表决。安吉拉说她不投。吉姆说没人关心。哦。吉姆，你搞什么鬼？这可真有点吉姆式的傲慢。吉姆式的傲慢。
Did you notice what Pam said in the scene? What did Pam say? Pam says, did you see her with her bangs? Oh, and lady, this made me laugh out loud because I have just recently gotten bangs. People have a lot of opinions about it. They do have opinions about my bangs. But what made me laugh was that before I got my bangs,
你注意到帕姆在这场戏里说了什么吗？帕姆说什么了？帕姆说，你看到她留刘海的样子了吗？哦，天哪，这把我逗得哈哈大笑，因为我最近刚剪了刘海。大家对此有很多看法。他们对我的刘海确实有很多看法。但让我笑的是，在我剪刘海之前，
I of course Googled images of people with bangs. You have to do research. You don't just, you got to look at all the pictures. You Googled people with bangs. You texted me, I think I'm going to get bangs. Yeah. To which I replied, oh no. I said, I think I'm going to get bangs right now
我当然在谷歌上搜索了留刘海的人的照片。你得做调研。你不能随便乱来，你得看所有的照片。你谷歌了留刘海的人。你发短信给我，我想要剪刘海了。是的。对此我回复道，哦，不。我说，我想要现在就剪刘海，
because like I was getting a haircut in the moment. By the time you replied, it was done. I know. I was like, oh, I was busy with the kids. I decided we were going to paint. I bought the canvas and all the paint stuff. We're outside. We'd made this huge mess.
因为当时我正在理发。等你的回复时，已经剪完了。我知道。我想，哦，我正忙着带孩子。我决定我们要画画。我买了画布和所有的颜料。我们在外面。弄得一团糟。
I'd set my phone aside so I didn't get paint on it. And then I just thought I'd check in, see what's happening. And I see this text from you that's half an hour old that says, I think I'm going to get bangs now. And I was like, oh no, I didn't get to weigh in. But lady, I think they're adorable. I think they're super cute because they're curly. I'm loving it.
我把手机放在一边，免得沾上颜料。然后我只是想查看一下，看看发生了什么。我看到了你半小时前发来的短信，上面写着，我想要现在就剪刘海。当时我想，哦，不，我没赶上发表意见。不过，天哪，我觉得它们很可爱。我觉得它们超级可爱，因为它们是卷的。我太喜欢了。
I bring it up because one of the people I saw in my research was Hillary Swank with bangs. So when Pam said this in the scene, it made me laugh. But I really based my bangs on some like Mia Farrow from Hannah and her sisters. You look very 70s kind of like beachy wave with bangs. A little bit of Terry Gar. Terry Gar wore some bangs like no one's business.
我提起这个是因为我在研究时看到的一个人就是留着刘海的希拉里·斯万克。所以当帕姆在剧场里这么说时，把我逗笑了。但我剪刘海其实是以《汉娜姐妹》里的米娅·法罗为原型的。你看上去非常有70年代那种海滩波浪卷发加刘海的感觉。有点像泰瑞·加尔。泰瑞·加尔留刘海简直无人能敌。
That's right. But my main inspiration was probably Stevie Nicks. And I will admit that after getting my bangs, I did style my hair in a full Stevie Nicks. And then I took pictures and I put them side by side. I was too shy to post. I want to see the side by side. You want to see my Stevie Nicks picture?
没错。但我的主要灵感来源可能是史蒂薇·尼克斯。我得承认，剪完刘海后，我确实把头发做成了一个完全的史蒂薇·尼克斯造型。然后我拍了照片，把它们并排放在一起。我当时太害羞了，没好意思发出来。我想看并排的照片。你想看我的史蒂薇·尼克斯照片吗？
Oh my god. Do you have it on your phone? Yeah. I mean, I really did this. Oh my god. Jenna, this is amazing. Oh, you kind of did the same mouth expression. I tried it.
哦，天哪。你手机里有吗？对。我是说，我真的这么干了。哦，天哪。珍娜，这太惊艳了。哦，你连嘴部表情都学进去了。我试过了。
I put on the same necklace. I did like a whole thing. Oh, you did. We got to put that in Office Ladies Pod Stories, please. It's okay. I mean, I'm doing a whole pouty mouth, so I got a little bit like shy. You even did the dark eyeliner.
我戴上了同样的项链。我整了一套。哦，你还真搞了。我们得把这个放进《办公室女郎》播客故事里，拜托。没关系。我是说，我做了一个嘟嘴的表情，所以显得有点害羞。你甚至还画了深色眼线。
I did. I'm telling you. She was my inspo. This was a whole afternoon. I thought I knew your life. This was a whole day. I didn't know what was happening. I mean, I had to take off my glasses for the picture.
我画了。我跟你说。她是我的灵感来源。这是整整一个下午。我以为我很了解你的生活。这是整整一天。我当时都不知道发生了什么。我是说，拍照时我不得不摘下眼镜。
I know. Which actually made it a little hard to take the picture. Because I couldn't see through. Tell me about it. I can't tell you how many photos I've taken of Josh and the kids. Because you know, when you're like a family, one parent has to take the picture. Yeah.
我知道。这其实让拍照变得有点困难。因为我看不清。别提了。我无法告诉你我给乔希和孩子们拍了多少照片。因为你知道的，当你们是一个家庭时，总得有一个家长负责拍照。是的。
And half the time I don't have my glasses, because I'm not good about wearing them. And Josh will be like, babe, these are out of focus. And I'm like, I can't tell. I just click. I love how we literally could not be more off topic right now. We are so off topic. Okay.
而且有一半时间我都没戴眼镜，因为我不太习惯戴。乔希就会说，宝贝，这些都对焦不上。然后我就说，我看不出来。我只管按快门。我喜欢我们现在 literalmente 跑题跑得没边了。我们跑题太严重了。好吧。
All right. We'll get back to it. Let's get back on topic. All right. All right. All right. So we are now, oh God, you guys, we're about to talk about a scene I absolutely loved.
好吧。我们扯回来。让我们回到正题上来。好啦。好啦。好啦。所以我们现在，哦天哪，伙计们，我们要聊一场我绝对深爱的戏了。
It's a driving scene between Dwight and Michael. They're headed to Prince Family Paper. Did you notice how much they bicker in this scene? They're like an old married couple. I loved it. They bicker about who would seduce the fictional daughter. They don't even know if this person exists. Yeah.
那是德怀特和迈克尔之间的一场车内戏。他们正前往普林斯家族纸业。你注意到他们在这一幕里吵得有多厉害了吗？他们就像一对老夫老妻。我太喜欢了。他们为谁会去勾引那个虚构的女儿而争吵。他们甚至不知道这个人是否存在。是的。
And they bicker about Denny's and IHOP. They bicker about the clouds. Dwight says, get your clouds right. Michael tells them to shut up. But I have a background catch. What is it? Oh, it sent me down a Google path, Jenna. All right.
他们还为丹尼斯餐厅和国际煎饼屋（IHOP）争吵。他们为云争吵。德怀特说，把你的云管好。迈克尔让他闭嘴。但我发现了一个背景彩蛋。是什么？哦，这让我开启了一段谷歌搜索之旅，珍娜。好的。
So whenever we have driving scenes, we always look for palm trees, right? Yeah. Spot the palm tree. And this one, I recognize the street they were on. It's Chandler Boulevard. It's a residential street. And guess what else I recognized? What?
所以每当有开车戏时，我们总是会寻找棕榈树，对吧？是的。寻找棕榈树。在这一场里，我认出了他们所在的街道。那是钱德勒大道。那是一条住宅街道。你猜我还认出了什么？什么？
It was trash day. And there were blue recycle bins in every driveway. I took a few photos. Okay. I'll put those in Pod. So then I thought, is that what the recycled trash bins look like in Scranton? Mm. And that took me to the recycling laws for Lackawanna County.
那是垃圾回收日。每个车道上都有蓝色的回收垃圾桶。我拍了几张照片。好的。我会把那些发到播客里。然后我想，斯克兰顿的回收垃圾桶也是长这样的吗？嗯。这把我带到了拉克瓦纳县的回收法规上。
Oh. Hang with me because there's a woman named Barbara who I am now fascinated by. First of all, that is not what recycle bins look like in Lackawanna County. So theirs are like these blue round tubs. Okay. And unless they've changed, you guys can correct me. Ours are these like skinny rectangles with lids. Yep.
哦。听我讲，因为有一个叫芭芭拉的女人，我现在对她着迷了。首先，拉克瓦纳县的回收垃圾桶根本不是长这样的。他们的像是那种蓝色的圆桶。好吧。而且除非它们变了，你们可以纠正我。我们的那种是带盖子的细长长方形。是的。
So here's an article I read from April of 2019. Barbara Giovanoli is the recycling coordinator for Lackawanna County. Barbara shared that the recycling center in Lackawanna County accepts plastics and glass bottles and jars, aluminum, still cans, as well as newspaper. It is a dual stream system. They have containers, bottles, jars and cans in one and paper fibers separately. They do not accept plastic bags, take out containers or pizza boxes. And apparently, lady, the recycle centers get all kinds of wacky things.
这是我读到的一篇2019年4月份的文章。芭芭拉·焦瓦诺利是拉克瓦纳县的回收协调员。芭芭拉分享说，拉克瓦纳县的回收中心接受塑料、玻璃瓶和罐子、铝罐、钢罐以及报纸。这是一个双流系统。他们将容器、瓶子、罐子和罐头放在一个里面，纸类纤维分开存放。他们不接受塑料袋、外卖盒或披萨盒。显然，伙计们，回收中心会收到各种各样古怪的东西。
People put all kinds of crazy things in the recycle bins. Barbara has a tip for you. She wants you to know. She says there's an easy way to remind yourself what can and cannot be recycled at the Lackawanna County Recycling Center. Quote, ask yourself, is it a bottle? Is it a jar? If the answer is no, that means it has to be thrown away.
人们把各种疯狂的东西塞进回收垃圾桶。芭芭拉有一个小贴士要送给大家。她希望你们知道。她说有一个简单的方法可以提醒自己拉克瓦纳县回收中心什么可以回收、什么不能回收。引述她的话，“问问自己，它是瓶子吗？它是罐子吗？如果答案是否定的，那就意味着它必须被扔进垃圾桶。”
I want to meet Barbara. I want to meet Barbara. I want to meet Barbara. It's real simple. Ask yourself. Is this a jar? Is this a bottle? No.
我想见芭芭拉。我想见芭芭拉。我想见芭芭拉。很简单。问问自己。这是个罐子吗？这是个瓶子吗？不是。
Trash. Wow. Mm-hmm. We have to meet her. We have to meet her. Anyway, this was a random thing I noticed in the background. No palm tree siding, several recycle bins. Also, in the scene for those of you guys keeping track of how many times Michael Skarn has mentioned
垃圾。哇。嗯哼。我们得去见她。我们得去见她。总之，这是我在背景里注意到的一个随机的事。没有棕榈树的踪迹，有好几个回收垃圾桶。另外，在这一幕里，对于那些一直在统计迈克尔·斯卡恩在剧中被提及多少次的伙计们来说，
in the series, this is one of them because it's going to be Michael's alias, and then they get into a real heated argument. I mean, that has history about Denny's and IHOP. Yeah. They're going to rendezvous after they get the info. Michael says at IHOP, and Dwight's like, I did not agree to IHOP. Socialist. Yeah.
这是其中一次，因为这将成为迈克尔的化名，然后他们陷入了一场真正的激烈争论。我是说，那是关于丹尼斯和IHOP的历史遗留问题。是的。他们打算在收集完情报后碰头。迈克尔说在IHOP，而德怀特说，我可没同意去IHOP。社会主义者。是的。
He's like, you socialist. I'm going to Denny's. And Michael's like, you were going to IHOP and you will have pancakes and you will like it. What do you like? Do you have strong feelings about IHOP or Denny's? I really don't, but I would say I've had IHOP more because there was one right on campus when I went to college, basically like across the street, and we would walk over there.
他说，你这个社会主义者。我要去丹尼斯。迈克尔就说，你要去IHOP，你得吃煎饼，而且你会喜欢的。你喜欢什么？你对IHOP或丹尼斯有什么强烈的感觉吗？我真的没有，但我得说我去IHOP更多一点，因为我上大学时，校园里就有一家，基本上就在马路对面，我们会走过去。
And there's also one by my kid's pediatrician office. So I've just been to IHOP more. I would say that if I'm looking for a pancake, IHOP is going to come to mind. But I want to say these words to you. Oh, what? Moons over my hammy. Oh, is that? That's a Denny's special.
而且我孩子的儿科医生诊所旁也有一家。所以我去IHOP的次数更多。如果要找煎饼的话，IHOP会浮现在我的脑海里。但我想要对你说出这些话。哦，什么？满月火腿三明治。哦，是那个吗？那是丹尼斯的特色菜。
That's a Denny's special. And it's real good. Okay. So if I'm wanting more of an egg sandwich, I'm going to have to head to Denny's. And now I'm just craving breakfast. I know me too, Kina. Well, these guys do eventually get to their destination of Prince Family Paper. It's in like a little strip mall.
那是丹尼斯的特色菜。而且真的很好吃。好吧。所以如果我想吃更多的鸡蛋三明治，我得去丹尼斯。现在我开始疯狂想吃早餐了。我知道我也是，基娜。好吧，这两个家伙终于到达了他们的目的地——普林斯家族纸业。它在一个类似小型购物中心的地方。
Right. And I got a location alert. Let's do it. We rented an empty mini mall near the corner of Laurel Canyon and Victory Boulevard in North Hollywood, California. We rented a whole mini mall. I guess we did because Randy said our location manager, Kyle Alexander, had to find a location where we could have some sort of office front that had all windows because we assumed that
没错。我收到了一个外景警报。我们开始吧。我们在加州北好莱坞劳urel Canyon和Victory大道交汇处附近租了一个空的迷你购物中心。我们租下了整个迷你购物中心。我想是的，因为兰迪说我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大必须找到一个地方，在那里我们可以有一个带有全景玻璃的办公场所，因为我们假设
if they were going undercover, they couldn't bring a documentary crew with them. Oh, that's so smart. I didn't even think about that. When I watched every single shot is through the glass. Yes. And so they had to be able to have a total glass front on this office. But then we also needed this giant parking lot. So he was able to find all of that in this little empty mini mall.
如果他们是去卧底，他们就不能带上纪录片摄制组。哦，太聪明了。我甚至都没想到这一点。当我观看时，每一个镜头都是透过玻璃拍的。是的。所以他们必须在这个办公室能有一个完全是玻璃的前面。但同时我们还需要一个巨大的停车场。所以他在这个废弃的小型迷你购物中心里找到了这一切。
I want Kyle to come on the show. Me too. He's like the master of every amazing location. So good. Get this. We had to bring all those cars. And did you notice the fakie snow residue? We put fakie snow residue on all the cars.
我想让凯尔上节目。我也是。他是每个惊艳外景的幕后大师。太棒了。你听着。我们得把所有的车都运过去。你注意到那些假雪残留物了吗？我们在所有的车上都弄了假雪残留物。
They're still dirty from last week. I know. And then our production designer, Michael Gallenberg, had to create the entire Prince Family paper offices from scratch. Michael, we want you one too. Michael and Kyle, we want you one. We're coming for you. So they're in the car and Dwight's got a little pair of binoculars and they're coming
它们上面还带着上周的脏污呢。我知道。然后我们的美术指导迈克尔·盖伦伯格必须从零开始搭建整个普林斯家族纸业的办公室。迈克尔，我们也想让你来。迈克尔和凯尔，我们想让你们俩都来。我们找你们来啦。所以他们在车里，德怀特拿着一小副双筒望远镜，正在
up with their plan. Dwight's binoculars are like industrial looking. They look like they have night vision. Yeah. And then here is my question. Through this whole scene, they are eating. What are they eating? Is it a giant can of nuts?
制定他们的计划。德怀特的望远镜看起来很工业风。看起来就像带有夜视功能一样。是的。然后我有这么一个问题。在整场戏中，他们一直在吃东西。他们在吃什么？是一大罐坚果吗？
I tried to zoom in. What is it? Did you see it? I did. I did take a picture. I actually loved the blooper for this scene so much that I filmed the blooper and I sent it to Rain and texted him and I was like, what are you guys eating? And he was cracking up.
我试着放大看了。那是什么？你看到了吗？我看到了。我确实拍了一张照片。其实我太喜欢这一段的NG花絮了，以至于我把花絮录了下来，发给雷因，还给他发短信问，你们俩到底在吃什么？他当时笑疯了。
He said, Angie, I am pretty sure those were smoked almonds. Yeah. They looked like almonds, but they had like stuff on them. Yeah. And he was pretty sure they were smoked almonds. And while they're eating these almonds, they decide on a signal that they need to give each other if there's danger. Yeah.
他说，安吉，我几乎可以肯定那是烟熏杏仁。是的。它们看起来像杏仁，但上面沾了些调料。是的。他非常确定那是烟熏杏仁。就在他们吃着这些杏仁的时候，他们决定了一个信号，如果有危险，他们必须给彼此发出这个信号。是的。
They need to get out of there. And Dwight says, you got to lick your lips. And Michael does a quick lick. Meanwhile, they're eating these almonds the whole time and Dwight goes, no, like this and does this big like, think, yeah, and in the process of doing this, they started laughing and when they did Rain in his laughter in his goof off, he spit like projectile almond and like flew and hit Steve in the face. I have the blooper clip.
他们得从那儿逃跑。德怀特说，你必须舔一下嘴唇。然后迈克尔飞快地舔了一下。与此同时，他们全程都在吃这些杏仁，德怀特说，不对，应该这样，然后做了这样一个巨大的、思考的动作，是的，就在做这个动作的过程中，他们开始笑起来，当他们笑的时候，雷因在笑闹中，像喷射一样吐出了一块半嚼烂的杏仁，直接飞过去砸到了史蒂夫的脸上。我有NG花絮片段。
We're going to need a signal to bolt out of there at the slightest sign of danger. Okay. I'm not signaling as with your lips. Let me see. No, no, no. Like this. Oh, no. Oh, dude, I'm so sorry.
如果有任何危险迹象，我们需要一个信号逃出去。好吧。我可不会像你那样用嘴唇做信号。让我看看。不，不，不。应该这样。哦，不。哦，老兄，太抱歉了。
Oh, I'm so sorry, dude. He sprayed the side of his face with a wet half chewed almond. I mean, you can hear it come out of his mouth. You really can. And then rain felt so bad and he grabs like a tissue and he starts in the moment just reacted. He's wiping Steve's face. Oh my gosh, it's so good.
哦，老兄，太对不起了。他把半嚼烂的湿杏仁喷了史蒂夫一脸。我是说，你能听到它从他嘴里喷出来的声音。真的听得到。然后雷因感到非常抱歉，他抓起一张纸巾，当下就做出了反应，开始擦史蒂夫的脸。哦天哪，太搞笑了。
It's so good. Michael then has a talking head where he says that in nature, there is a food chain where the bigger shark eats the littler shark and so on until it gets to the single cell shark. Exactly. And basically, you know, that's what they are. They're sharks. And then as he's getting out of the car, he's doing the whole Jaws theme. He goes into Prince Family Paper.
太棒了。迈克尔随后有一个单人镜头，他说在自然界中存在着食物链，大鲨鱼吃小鲨鱼，以此类推，直到单细胞鲨鱼。没错。基本上，你知道的，他们就是这种鲨鱼。然后当他下车时，他嘴里哼着《大白鲨》的主题曲。他走进了普林斯家族纸业。
He introduces himself as Michael Skarn and he sits down and he starts having just the most wonderful conversation with Mr. Prince. Michael's doing kind of a good job. He is. And you know, he completely charms Mr. Prince. He does. He's a lawyer who knows a lot about paper because he is a genius about some things but not everything.
他介绍自己叫迈克尔·斯卡恩，坐了下来，开始与普林斯先生进行最美妙的交谈。迈克尔其实干得还不错。他确实不错。你知道的，他把普林斯先生迷得神魂颠倒。他确实做到了。他是一个对纸张了解很多的律师，因为他在某些方面是个天才，但不是所有方面。
Not everything. What's this? Is this a phone? Is this a phone? Mr. Roger Prince can't get enough of it. He's cackling, laughing. He also learns that Prince Family Paper is a three-person operation. Yeah.
并非所有方面。这是什么？这是电话吗？这是电话吗？罗杰·普林斯先生对此爱不释手。他咯咯笑着，大笑起来。他还得知普林斯家族纸业是一家三口经营的企业。是的。
Mr. Prince, his wife, Linda, and his son. Yes. And his granddaughter, Rebecca, sits in the corner. Angela, I did a guest star breakdown for the members of Prince Family Paper. Oh, great. So, Roger Prince, the father, was played by Dan Desmond, and I found this really interesting. From 1990 to 2001, he was in five different episodes of Law & Order and he played a different character each time.
普林斯先生、他的妻子琳达和他的儿子。对。他的孙女丽贝卡坐在角落里。安吉拉，我为“普林斯家族纸业”的成员做了一份客串演员的分析。哦，太棒了。扮演父亲罗杰·普林斯的演员是丹·德斯蒙德，我觉得这真的很有趣。从1990年到2001年，他曾参演过五集不同的《法律与秩序》，而且每次扮演的角色都不同。
Let me tell you, I love Law & Order and they do that. I know. They pull back. One time you're a police officer, the next time you're a judge. I was literally just watching Law & Order Marathon and I swear, Jeremy Sisto was like just a guest star, like a guy. And then in the next episode, he was a police officer in like a series regular. No, I don't doubt it.
实话实说，我超爱《法律与秩序》，他们确实会那样。我懂。他们会反复用演员。这次你是警察，下次你可能就是法官。我刚才真的在看《法律与秩序》马拉松连播，我发誓，杰瑞米·西斯托就像只是个客串演员，一个路人甲。然后到了下一集，他居然就成了警察，差不多是剧里的常规演员了。不，我对此深信不疑。
Did that happen? I feel like the rules of Law & Order are sort of like a soap opera. Yeah. You can come back in many different forms. Well, they loved Dan Desmond over at Law & Order. He was also in the movie Bruce Almighty and most recently in the mini-series Little Fires Everywhere. Gang, gang.
真的发生过吗？我觉得《法律与秩序》的规则有点像肥皂剧。是的。你可以用各种不同的身份回归。好吧，《剧组的人》非常喜欢丹·德斯蒙德。他还出演过电影《冒牌天神》，最近的作品则是迷你剧《星星之火》。帮派，帮派。
Roger Prince Jr. was played by Dan Backendall. You might recognize him for his recurring roles on Veep or the Goldbergs or Space Force. He was also a regular on Life and Pieces. He has also been on Law & Order, but just one episode. Okay. Linda Price was played by Sharon Blackwood, who recently appeared in two episodes of Ozark has never been on Law & Order. None of them have been on Monk.
小罗杰·普林斯由丹·巴肯达尔扮演。你可能在《副总统》、《戈德堡一家》或《太空部队》中看过他饰演的常驻角色。他也是《生活点滴》的常驻演员。他还演过《法律与秩序》，不过只有一集。好吧。琳达·普林斯由莎朗·布莱克伍德扮演，她最近在《黑钱胜地》的两集中露过面，但从来没有演过《法律与秩序》。他们当中没有人演过《神探阿蒙》。
What? None. Craziness. Okay, wait. I have a Law & Order story. What is it? It's one of my more embarrassing audition stories. You auditioned for Law & Order?
什么？一个都没有。太疯狂了。好吧，等等。我有一个关于《法律与秩序》的故事。什么故事？这是我最尴尬的试镜经历之一。你试镜过《法律与秩序》？
I did. Shocker didn't get it. You'll know why. You guys, I was so excited. I love Law & Order. I would watch the marathon on TNT. I loved it. Yeah, same.
我试过。太震惊了，没选上。你们听了就知道为什么了。天哪，我当时太兴奋了。我超级喜欢《法律与秩序》。我经常看特纳电视网（TNT）的马拉松连播。我太爱了。是的，我也是。
I still watch the marathon. I still watch it. If it's on, I'm watching it. All right. I got an audition. I was so excited. And I was very new to auditioning. Okay.
我现在还在看马拉松连播。我依然在看。只要它在播，我就会看。好吧。我得到了一个试镜机会。我当时超级兴奋。而且我当时对试镜非常陌生。好吧。
I had only booked a few commercials. It was to be a real estate agent. You know how the guys at the top of the show would like interview people while they were at work? And they're always too busy. They're always too busy to talk. They've got to get somewhere. Yeah, yeah.
我只拍过几支商业广告。试镜的角色是一个房地产经纪人。你知道剧集开头的那种场景吗，警察会在别人工作的时候盘问他们？他们总是太忙了。他们总是忙得没空说话。他们还得赶去某个地方。对，对。
This murder you're investigating is a big inconvenience to me. I have to show a house. Yeah, exactly. Are we done? Are we done? Exactly. I had just watched an episode where they were questioning these guys that were loading trash into like a garbage truck.
你正在调查的这桩谋杀案对我来说是个巨大的麻烦。我得带人看房呢。对，完全如此。我们说完了吗？说完了吗？没错。我刚好看过一集，里面盘问的是几个正在往垃圾车上装垃圾的家伙。
Yep. They did not stop loading their trash. No. They're going to keep, they're annoyed. I'm busy here. I got to keep the truck moving. Always. Always.
没错。他们根本没有停下装垃圾的手。没有。他们一直在干活，觉得很烦。我很忙的好不好。我得让卡车继续开呢。总是这样。总是这样。
I had this in my brain. In the script, it said, they questioned a real estate agent. As she is setting out her signs for the day with the little flag, her showing signs. Yeah. Right? You know those things. Lady, I'm not even joking. I think I literally just saw this episode.
我把这个画面印在了脑子里。剧本上写着，他们盘问了一名房地产经纪人。当时她正在把小旗子标志摆出来，也就是房产出售的指示牌。没错，对吧？你知道那种东西。大姐，我真没开玩笑。我觉得我literally刚刚看过这一集。
Are you kidding? Yeah, there was a blonde woman and she had to be blonde because that was part of the plot, by the way, and she was talking to them while putting out the little sign for selling the house. Okay. Oh my God. I saw the part you didn't get. Okay.
你在开玩笑吧？对，有个金发女人，顺便说一句，她必须是金发女郎，因为这是剧情需要，当时她一边把卖房子的标牌摆出来，一边跟他们说话。好吧。哦，天哪。我看到了你没被选上的那部分。好吧。
I went there and I'm like, okay, I got this. So it's the casting agent, she's sitting across from her desk. I was so nervous, but I was like, I got this. I got this. Literally, it's three lines. It's like three or four lines. That's it. All I had in my brain was, you will not interrupt me from putting out my real estate sign.
我当时去了，心想，好吧，这回稳了。然后是选角导演，她坐在办公桌对面。我紧张得要命，但还是自我安慰说，我行的，我绝对行。说真的，台词只有三句。大概三四句台词。就这样。我脑子里唯一的念头就是：你休想打扰我摆房产中介的牌子。
Yeah. That's the energy. Jenna, in this woman's office, I moved two chairs out of my way. Her chairs. Her chairs. We had to put up your sign. I moved them. And then when we started the scene, I am setting things out.
对。就是这种气势。詹娜，在这个女人的办公室里，我把两把椅子搬开，腾出地方。她的椅子。是她的椅子。我们得把你的牌子摆好。我把椅子搬走了。然后当我们开始演的时候，我开始摆道具。
Setting it out. Moving things. Yeah. Busy. Busy. I'm moving things. And it must have been really distracting. She said, you know what?
摆道具。挪动东西。对。忙碌。忙碌。我在挪动东西。那一定非常让人分心。她说，你知道吗？
I'm going to stop you. Oh no. You never want to hear that in an auction. No. She was like, you're doing too much. Okay. You're doing too much. Stop moving things around and just deliver the lines.
我要打断你一下。噢，不。在试镜时你最不想听到这句话。没有。她说，你演得太多了。好吧。你演得太夸张了。别再搬来搬去挪东西了，直接念台词就行。
And I said, okay. This went into my brain as, don't touch her chairs, but do some great space work. Yeah. Mime it. Now I mime putting out real estate signs, mime, mime, mime, mime, mime. I must have just looked ridiculous. Yeah. I didn't get the part.
我说，好的。我的脑回路把这话理解成了：别碰她的椅子，但要做一些很棒的无实物表演。对。假装去演。现在我假装摆房产中介的牌子，假装，假装，假装，假装，假装。我当时看起来一定荒谬极了。对。我没拿到这个角色。
I did too much business. You know who's been on law and order? Who? Rainn Wilson. Oh. He plays a creepy janitor. Oh, I need to see it. During one of my marathons, I was just sitting there and I was like, oh, it's Rainn.
我的动作戏太多了。你们知道谁演过《法律与秩序》吗？谁？雷恩·威尔逊。哦。他演了一个诡异的看门人。哦，我得去看看。在我的某次马拉松观影中，我坐在那儿心想，哦，是雷恩。
Rainn. There he is. You know, who else has been on Jackie DeBotton? Oh. Yeah. She was just on in the marathon I watched. Jackie. Well, if I ever get to audition for law and order again, I'm not going to do a lot of business.
雷恩。他就在那儿。你知道还有谁演过吗？杰基·德博顿。哦。是的。我看的马拉松里刚好有她出场。杰基。好吧，如果我以后还有机会去试镜《法律与秩序》，我绝对不会再加那么多乱七八糟的动作了。
Don't do it. Finally, Rebecca Prince, the little girl, was played by Emily Evan Ray. And she's going to come back in a couple of episodes, actually. Emily recently produced and directed a documentary called Stop the Bleed about the mass shooting in Parkland, Florida. My gosh. Emily was born and raised in Parkland and she made the movie to give a voice to the family, friends, and the community who were affected.
别加。最后，小女孩丽贝卡·普林斯由艾米莉·埃文·雷饰演。而且她接下来还要在好几集里出场。其实，艾米莉最近制作并导演了一部名为《制止流血》的纪录片，讲的是佛罗里达州帕克兰的大规模枪击事件。天哪。艾米莉在帕克兰出生长大，她拍这部电影是为了给那些受到影响的家人、朋友和社区发声。
She won the audience award at the Fort Lauderdale Film Festival for Best Documentary. Wow. Yeah. That's what she's been up to. That's amazing. Yes. Well, on that note, I think we should take a break and then we'll be back to join the group at Dunder Mifflin because they have more to say.
她凭借这部作品获得了劳德代尔堡国际电影节的最佳纪录片观众奖。哇。是的。这就是她最近在忙的事情。太了不起了。是的。好吧，借此机会，我觉得我们应该休息一下，然后回来加入邓德米夫林的小团队，因为他们还有更多话要说。
There's a big debate going on. Well, we're back in the bullpen. Okay. And the debate is still going on, the hot or not. There's a whole debate about what is attractive hot. Right. Kevin has a lot to say. The most ever.
有一场大辩论正在进行。好了，我们回到了公共办公区。好吧。辩论仍在继续，关于谁性感谁不性感。大家对什么是吸引人的性感展开了激烈的讨论。对。凯文有很多话要说。比以往任何时候都多。
But first, Jim is going to comment that, you know, sometimes we forget to think of celebrities as real people. Kevin sort of says, it's a gut thing, right? And then Jim gets all up in Kevin's ear and gives like a husky whisper. With a sultry, paints a picture of Hillary Swank coming up to him. We got so much mail about John Krasinski's husky voice to Kevin in this episode. It was like just, I was too shy to put it in my document. Oh, come on.
但首先，吉姆评论说，你知道，有时我们忘了把名人当成真实的人来看待。凯文有点像是说，这是一种直觉，对吧？然后吉姆凑到凯文耳边，用沙哑的嗓音低语。带着一种性感撩人的语调，描绘了希拉里·斯万克向他走来的画面。我们收到了雪片般关于约翰·卡拉辛斯基在本集中对凯文发出沙哑嗓音的邮件。当时的情况是，我太害羞了，没把它写进我的文档里。哦，拜托。
Give me one nugget, something you remember someone saying. One nugget. Basically, this woman said, John Krasinski could debate anything in my ear if he uses that voice. It was so funny to me. But I did write down this one because Laura B needed a soapbox moment, so I thought I'd give it to her. Okay, Laura.
透露一点嘛，哪怕是你记得别人说过的一个小细节。一个小细节。基本上，这个女人说，如果约翰·卡拉辛斯基用那种声音在我的耳边说话，他辩论什么我都听。我觉得太搞笑了。但我确实记下了这一条，因为劳拉·B需要一个发表高论的机会，所以我想把这个机会给她。好吧，劳拉。
Laura says this, it always bothers me that when Stanley asks why they're making a distinction between beautiful and hot, Kevin says, quote, a painting can be beautiful, but I don't want to bang a painting. But later in the episode, Kevin turns around and tells Jim to respect the game after Jim narrates the saucy scenario with Hillary Swank. And Kevin says, no, it's, is she hot, not, would you bang her? But he just used the same phrase to explain why he wouldn't bang a painting. Kevin, you can't use the same argument on different sides.
劳拉是这么说的：一直让我感到困惑的是，当斯坦利问他们为什么要区分“美丽”和“性感”时，凯文说，原话是：“一幅画可以很美丽，但我不想和一幅画上床。”但在这集的后面，凯文却转过身，让吉姆“尊重游戏规则”，当时吉姆刚描述了与希拉里·斯万克的火辣情景。凯文说：“不，这是……她性不性感的问题，而不是你想不想跟她上床的问题。”但他刚刚才用过完全相同的逻辑来解释为什么他不想和一幅画上床。凯文，你不能在不同的立场上使用同一个论据啊。
That's what Laura B says. She says, you respect the game, Kevin. Yeah, Kevin. Laura, we hear you. Angela has been over and accounting. She hasn't wanted to participate, but she can't take it anymore. All right, Kevin holding court like this, she's had it. She gets up and she says, okay, I wasn't going to dignify this discussion by getting
这就是劳拉·B想说的。她说，尊重游戏规则吧，凯文。没错，凯文。劳拉，我们听到你的心声了。安吉拉一直在财务部那边。她本来不想参与的，但她实在忍无可忍了。好吧，看凯文在那儿独断专行、大放厥词，她受够了。她站起来说，好吧，我本不想通过介入来抬高这场讨论的逼格，
involved, but I don't even get the discussion. Hot is a temperature people, but Kevin deserves to lose for what he said. So yes, she's hot. She's hot as heck. She's a female Boris Becker. I love that Boris Becker is it for Angela Martin. Who knew? I know.
但我甚至都无法理解这场讨论。性感是一个温度概念，各位，但凯文因为他说的话，活该输掉。所以，是的，她很性感。她性感得要命。她简直就是女版的鲍里斯·贝克尔。我太喜欢安吉拉·马丁居然把鲍里斯·贝克尔当成梦中情人这事了。谁能想到呢？我知道。
I didn't even realize Angela Martin was a tennis fan. Really? Yeah. Well, y'all, Boris Becker was a German tennis player who shot to stardom when he won the Wimbledon Men's singles title in 1985. It was significant because he was only 17 years old and he was the first unceded player and the first German to win the Wimbledon singles title, as well as the youngest ever male Grand Slam singles champion.
我甚至都没意识到安吉拉·马丁还是个网球迷。真的吗？是的。各位，鲍里斯·贝克尔是一位德国网球运动员，他在1985年赢得温网男子单打冠军时一战成名。这意义重大，因为他当时年仅17岁，是温网历史上第一位非种子选手、第一位赢得温网单打冠军的德国人，也是有史以来最年轻的大满贯男子单打冠军。
It was huge. I watched it with my mom. She's a big, big tennis player. She's phenomenal. She was ranked by the USTA by her age group. I spent my whole childhood on a tennis court. Wow. Yeah.
这太轰动了。我和我妈妈一起看的。她是个超级超级大的网球迷。她非常厉害。她曾在美国网球协会（USTA）的同年龄组中拥有排名。我的整个童年都是在网球场度过的。哇。是的。
My mom is like... I did not know that about your mom. Yeah. My mom's a badass tennis player. We're a big tennis family, guys. There are two things that are always on at our house, either the weather or tennis because my mom has the tennis channel. Yeah.
我妈妈就像……我真不知道你妈还有这经历。对。我妈妈是个很厉害的网球高手。我们是一个网球大家庭，伙计们。在我们家，永远有两样东西在播放，要么是天气预报，要么就是网球，因为我妈订了网球频道。对。
And we'll watch old games. Oh, I'd love it when Boris Becker would play Stefan Egberg because my mom had shown me old games of Beyond Borg and he was the other big Swede, there was Stefan and Beyond Borg and Beyond Borg would play John McEnroe. Speaking of, Boris Becker played John McEnroe and it's one of the longest games in tennis history. It was the Davis Cup. It was six hours and something minutes.
我们会看过去的经典比赛。哦，我特别喜欢看鲍里斯·贝克尔对阵斯特凡·埃德伯格，因为我妈给我看过比约·博格的旧比赛，他（埃德伯格）是另一个伟大的瑞典人，当时有斯特凡和比约·博格，而比约·博格曾和约翰·麦肯罗对阵。说到这儿，鲍里斯·贝克尔和约翰·麦肯罗打过一场，那是网球史上历时最长的比赛之一。那是戴维斯杯。打了足足六个多小时。
Can you imagine playing tennis for six hours? No. Unbelievable. I can't imagine playing tennis for six minutes. Anyway, Boris Becker does it for Angela Martin. I think we should go back to Prince Family paper, lady. We forgot to mention that Dwight has come in, he's going to pretend to get a job there. He says, fire your son, I'll be your son.
你能想象打六个小时网球吗？不能。难以置信。我连想象打六分钟网球都做不到。不管怎样，鲍里斯·贝克尔就是安吉拉·马丁的菜。我觉得我们应该回到普林斯家族纸业那边，女士们。我们忘了提迪恩过来了，他假装要在那里找工作。他说，炒了你儿子，我来当你儿子。
You can visit him on the weekends. I know. He comes in like pulling a china cabinet. And he's going to explain to Mr. Prince just how awful his current boss is, you know, because he says, why are you looking for a new job? And he's like, well, my current boss is cruel. Terrible. Meanwhile, Michael's kind of walking around.
你可以周末去探望他。我懂。他走进来的时候还拖着一个中国瓷器陈列柜。他要向普林斯先生解释他目前的老板有多糟糕，你知道的，因为普林斯先生问他，你为什么要找新工作？他说，呃，我现在的老板很残忍。太糟糕了。与此同时，迈克尔在四处溜达。
He wants to get a photograph of their kind of territory map over there by Mrs. Prince. And then he offers to help her granddaughter with a math problem. I have to say, when I was watching these scenes, I was just so impressed with the detail that went into this little set. I know. Well, I was emailing with Michael Gallenberg about this particular set and he said, everything you see, they had to bring in. Crazy.
他想拍一张普林斯太太那边挂的领地地图的照片。然后他主动提出帮她孙女解一道数学题。我必须得说，当我看到这些场景时，我对这个小布景里的细节印象太深刻了。我知道。我和迈克尔·盖伦伯格通过邮件聊过这个特定的布景，他说，你看到的每一件东西，都是他们特意搬进来的。疯狂。
Crazy. I loved all the details too. Well, I noticed on that little girl's desk, did you see it? She had her own nameplate. I know. It says Rebecca. I know. And also on the desk are all of these little like hand painted ceramic animals, like the
太疯狂了。我也很喜欢所有的细节。对了，我在那个小女孩的桌子上注意到一个东西，你们看到了吗？她有自己的名牌。我知道。上面写着“丽贝卡”。我知道。而且桌子上还摆满了各种手绘的陶瓷小动物，就像
kind that your granddaughter would give to you. And also I noticed on the wall, there was one of those photo collages, love framed photos. They had clearly asked the actors to bring in some pictures and all of those details to me just like really set this up as a family business and it made the whole storyline even more heartbreaking. No, they had a whole family photo wall. I zoomed in, one is like a wedding photo. And then there's like your grandson in his baseball uniform holding his baseball bat.
你孙女会送给你的那种。我还注意到墙上挂着一个照片拼贴画，全是带框的照片。他们显然要求演员们带一些照片来，所有这些细节在我看来，真的把这里烘托成了一个家族企业，这让整个故事情节更加令人心碎。不，他们有一整面家庭照片墙。我放大看了一张，是一张婚礼照片。还有一张是你孙子穿着棒球服、手里拿着棒球棒的照片。
Yeah. And there was a big painting like your kids do at preschool where they take their hands and put it in paint and then they make their hand prints into flowers. Yes. Just like the most amazing details. I feel like this is Michael's true dream office because it is a real family. Yes. Angela, you're so right.
对。还有一幅巨大的画，就像你在幼儿园里看到的那样，孩子们把手浸在颜料里，然后把手印变成一朵朵花。是的。细节实在是太惊人了。我觉得这是迈克尔真正的梦中办公室，因为这是一个真正的家庭。是的。安吉拉，你说得太对了。
He wants his office to be his family. And this office is a family. I know. Well, that's going to weigh on his heartstrings. Well, as he wraps up his visit, he gets Mr. Prince to just hand him a list of their top clients. Oh, Mr. Prince, he's just so trusting. He's like, listen, if you want to see, we do a good job.
他希望他的办公室就是他的家庭。而这个办公室就是一个家庭。我知道。好吧，这会触动他心底最柔软的部分。好吧，当他的访问接近尾声时，他让普林斯先生直接把他们顶级客户的名单交给他。哦，普林斯先生，他太容易信任别人了。他说，听着，如果你想看，我们活干得很好。
Here's all of our references. Here's all of our clients. Oh, well Dwight and Michael immediately start licking their lips. Yeah. Time to get out of there. Time to get out of there. Dwight says, sir, can you give me a ride home? Michael's like, yeah.
这是我们所有的推荐信。这是我们所有的客户。哦，于是德怀特和迈克尔立刻开始垂涎三尺了。对。是时候离开那儿了。是时候离开那儿了。德怀特说，先生，你能顺便送我回家吗？迈克尔说，行。
And then they sprint. They walk. They hurry to the car. Get out. Peel out. Peel out. Because they know they got all the info. Yes.
然后他们一路小跑。他们走路。他们快步走向汽车。上车。倒车逃离。逃离现场。因为他们知道他们拿到了所有的资料。是的。
Well, as they're trying to flee, Michael runs over like the parking curb. It's so funny. He runs over the bumper. Yeah, I don't know what you call that thing. What do you call that? It's like a partition. It's like the cement block so you don't go into the other spot. I've done it.
好吧，在他们试图逃跑时，迈克尔直接把车开压上了停车场的路缘石。太搞笑了。他轧过了挡车桩。对，我不知道那东西叫什么。你们管那个叫什么？就像是一个隔离带。就像是防止你冲进别人车位的水泥块。我压过。
I've done it. But I haven't backed back over it. No, of course not. Once you realize you go over it. Just keep going. Just keep going. Well, I asked Randy how did we do this stunt? What'd he say?
我也压过。但我可没倒车再从上面轧过去。不，当然没有。一旦你意识到自己开上去了。那就继续开呗。那就继续开呗。好吧，我问了兰迪我们是怎么拍这个特技的？他怎么说？
He said we had two different identical cars. One that was totally normal and one that was pre-rigged with a damaged bumper. So Steve never damaged a car. And if you notice, the camera stays inside the car on Dwight and Michael. So what Steve was actually driving over were just a couple of sandbags. Well, it totally sold it. It did. It didn't add all that kind of crunching effect in editing.
他说我们准备了两辆一模一样的汽车。一辆完全正常，另一辆是预先做过手脚、带有受损保险杠的道具车。所以史蒂夫根本没有撞坏真车。如果你注意看，镜头一直停留在车内拍摄德怀特和迈克尔。所以史蒂夫实际上开过去的时候，压的只是一堆沙袋。好吧，这效果绝了。确实。他们在后期剪辑里加入的那种挤压变形的音效。
So yeah, fakie cement thing was actually sandbags and sound effects. The Prince family hears this commotion and they come running out. And of course, Mr. Prince, because he's so sweet, offers to fix the bumper. And they're like, no, no, no. We won't wait. No, please let us. We'll get a tow truck. And he's like, oh no, they're too expensive.
所以，那个假的水泥墩实际上是沙袋和音效做出来的。普林斯一家听到这个动静，都跑了出来。当然，普林斯先生人太好了，主动提出帮他们修好保险杠。而他们却说，不，不，不。我们不等了。不，请让我们来吧。我们去叫拖车。而他说，哦，不，拖车太贵了。我来搞定。
I got it. And Jenna, this scene made me think of my dad. It made me think of my dad too because of the duct tape. My dad would fix anything with duct tape. Same. My dad did this with my first car. The handle on my glove box broke. OK.
詹娜，这个场景让我想起了我爸。它也让我想起了我爸，因为提到了胶带。我爸会用胶带修好任何东西。一样。我爸对我第一辆车也是这样的。我手套箱的把手断了。好吧。
My dad duct taped it. You know what it's making me think of? What? Josh's duct tape is zip ties. All over the house. Your husband zip ties it. Our dad's would duct tape it. Yeah.
我爸用胶带把它粘上了。你知道这让我想起什么吗？什么？乔什的胶带就是扎带。全屋都是。你老公用扎带固定。我们的爸爸们会用胶带粘。对。
My dishwasher tray has been zip tied for four years. It finally fell apart. We had to get a new dishwasher. But you can pretty much fix anything with duct tape. Pretty much. Including a whole bumper. So now they're in the car. They're going to head back.
我家的洗碗机托盘用扎带绑了四年。直到它彻底散架。我们不得不买了个新洗碗机。不过你基本上可以用胶带修好任何东西。基本上是这样。包括一整根保险杠。所以现在他们上车了。他们要回去了。
Dwight still is celebrating. He wants to do high fives. He calls them the soccer family. I know. Dwight is that, like, young kid on the soccer field who doesn't know when to stop? Yeah. Like, you scored the goal and I'll stop taunting. Yeah.
德怀特还在庆祝。他想击掌。他管他们叫“足球家庭”。我懂。德怀特就像足球场上那种不知道什么时候该适可而止的小屁孩？对。就像，你都进球了，我还在那儿嘲讽个没完。对。
All right? Exactly. Michael is having some regrets. Yeah. Dwight tries to high five Michael. And Michael's like not having any of it. Yeah. So back in the office, Toby is studying Hilary Swank.
行了吧？没错。迈克尔开始有些后悔了。对。德怀特试图跟迈克尔击掌。而迈克尔完全不理他。对。回到办公室里，托比正在研究希拉里·斯万克。
Pam is going to make a speech. She's going to appeal to the ladies of the office. Yeah. What? Are we going to let the kevins of the world decide things for us? And then Oscar projects this picture of Hilary Swank's face with all this grid on it, right? Yeah. And he talks about coinophilia.
帕姆要发表一段演讲。她要向办公室里的女士们发出呼吁。对。怎么？难道我们要让世上的“凯文们”来替我们做决定吗？然后奥斯卡投影出了希拉里·斯万克的脸，上面画满了各种网格线，对吧？对。然后他谈到了美貌同型恋（coinophilia）。
The symmetry, right, of the face. So coinophilia is this, stay with me here, evolutionary hypothesis for explaining why certain animals seek mates that look a certain way. And it proposes that animals, including humans, find the symmetry of features most attractive. I read all about it. I barely understood it. Okay. It was very wordy.
也就是脸部的对称性，对吧？所以美貌同型恋是这样的——听我解释——这是一种进化假说，用来解释为什么某些动物会寻找长相特定的伴侣。它提出，包括人类在内的动物，会发现特征对称性最高的人最具吸引力。我读了所有关于它的资料。我几乎没听懂。好吧。里面有太多生僻词了。
But in ancient Greece, they created something called the golden ratio of beauty or Phi. It's a mathematical equation. And it says if your face possesses a specific set of ratios of distance between the different features on your face, they believed it could be mathematically proven that you had a perfect face. This equation is what Da Vinci used when he was creating his vertruvian man. Oh. That is what Oscars, I think, really talking about.
但在古希腊，他们创造了一种叫做“美丽黄金比例”或“黄金分割率（Phi）”的东西。这是一个数学方程式。它表明，如果你的脸部具备一组特定的特征间距比例，他们认为这可以在数学上证明你拥有一张完美的脸。达芬奇在创作他的《维特鲁威人》时，就是利用了这个方程式。哦。我觉得奥斯卡真正想说的就是这个。
I think he's talking about ratios. I don't think he's really talking about coinophilia. Stanley's going to address the group, and he makes a really moving speech about how he's trying to be more optimistic in life. And in years past, he might have been critical, but he's not going to be that person anymore. No. I liked this speech. I did, too.
我觉得他在讨论比例问题。我觉得他并不是真的在讨论美貌同型恋。斯坦利要对大家说话了，他发表了一番非常感人的演讲，谈到他是如何在生活中努力变得更加乐观。在过去几年里，他可能会持批判态度，但他不会再做那样的人了。不。我很喜欢这段演讲。我也是。
You know? He's saying, why are we doing this to one another? Let's just live our lives, basically. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Andy calls for a final vote on Hillary Swank's hotness. It's another tie. We discover this is what happens.
你知道吗？他是说，我们为什么要这样互相折磨？基本上就是，让我们好好过自己的日子吧。嗯哼。是的。安迪号召大家对希拉里·斯万克的性感与否进行最后一次投票。结果又是个平局。我们发现这就是结果。
People just argue their position. They don't listen. That's what Oscar says. Yeah, no one's moved. No one's moving. But Michael gets back to the office during all of this. He's clearly worked up. He goes in his office with Dwight.
大家只是在固执己见地争论。根本没人听别人说。奥斯卡就是这么说的。是的，没人被说服。没人改变想法。但迈克尔在这个时候回到了办公室。他显然情绪激动。他和德怀特一起进了办公室。
They shut the door. He doesn't want to go through with it. Yeah. Dwight knows that Michael is bailing, so he's going to try his best to convince Michael that what they did was right. And of course, he's going to use the one argument that will clearly point this out to Michael, which is a Lord of the Rings analogy. Dwight says there was a terrible war.
他们关上了门。他不想继续干下去了。对。德怀特知道迈克尔要打退堂鼓，所以他要尽最大努力说服迈克尔，他们做的事是正确的。当然，他会用那个能让迈克尔彻底明白的论据，也就是《指环王》的类比。德怀特说，曾有过一场可怕的战争。
Ugh, so many died. Far too many died. If Frodo hadn't destroyed the ring, then goodness itself might have died. I didn't understand that. I was Michael. I have questions. I wrote them down. Okay.
呃，死了太多人了。死的人实在太多了。如果弗罗多没有销毁魔戒，那么善良本身可能都会消亡。我没听懂。我当时就是迈克尔。我有疑问。我都记下来了。好吧。
I thought you might. Listen, I am not a Lord of the Rings expert. I don't want to get mail, guys. I just am a fan. I've seen the movies multiple times. I've read some of the books. It's a big commitment to get through them all. Okay?
我猜你会有。听着，我不是《指环王》专家。伙计们，别给我发邮件轰炸我。我只是个粉丝。我把电影看过好几遍。我也读过一些书。要把它们全看完是个巨大的工程。好吧？
I have not gotten through them all. Okay. Well, here's my first question. Okay. Who is the Lord of the Rings? Okay. Is it Frodo? No.
我还没全看完呢。好吧，我的第一个问题是。好吧。谁是《指环王》？好吧。是弗罗多吗？不是。
Is it the guy with the beard? No. It's not like a one person. What is the ring? Well, it's called the one ring. Right? The one ring to rule them all. Okay.
是那个大胡子吗？不是。这不是某一个人。魔戒是什么？好吧，它被称为“至尊魔戒”。对吧？统治众戒的至尊魔戒。好吧。
Oh, Lord. Okay. All right. Where do I even start? First of all, here's what I want to say. I know the battle that Dwight's referencing. I'm pretty sure it's the battle of the Black Gate, right? Which is the big, major battle for the War of the Ring.
哦，天哪。好吧。我该从哪里开始呢？首先，我想说的是：我知道德怀特提到的那场大战。我敢肯定是黑门之战，对吧？那是魔戒之战中最大、最关键的一场战役。
They fought it right in front of the gate, and they were trying to distract the Eye of Sauron because the Eye of Sauron tracks whoever holds the ring, and Frodo had the ring, and Frodo was trying to get to Mount Doom to drop it into the lava lake thing, right? That's the one place it can be destroyed. Why do I have to get rid of it? Why is he destroying it? Okay. Because it's innately evil.
他们在城门前进行战斗，他们试图转移索伦之眼的注意力，因为索伦之眼会追踪任何持有魔戒的人，而弗罗多拥有魔戒，弗罗多正试图前往末日火山，把它扔进岩浆湖里，对吧？那是唯一能摧毁它的地方。为什么我非得除掉它？他为什么要销毁它？好吧。因为它本质上是邪恶的。
I'll explain. Okay. So it's called the Lord of the Rings, but it's one ring. So it shouldn't be, why, it's not called Lord of the Rings. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
我来解释。好吧。所以它被称为“指环王（Lord of the Rings）”，但它只有一枚戒指。所以它不应该被叫……为什么它不叫“指环之王”呢？好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧。
So Bilbo Baggins, right? When he found the ring, Gollum had been hiding it. This is a really bad overview from me. Anyway, he gave it to Frodo, and you know, Gandalf realized that Bilbo Baggins, like when he had the ring, it kind of made him a different person. So Gandalf was like, something's up with that, you know? But there was this inscription, when you take the ring and you put it in the fire, because just fire can't kill it, dragon fire can't kill it.
所以，比尔博·巴金斯，对吧？当他找到这枚戒指时，咕噜一直把它藏着。我这个概括做得太烂了。不管怎样，他把戒指给了弗罗多，然后你知道的，甘道夫意识到比尔博·巴金斯，当他拥有这枚戒指时，它有点把他变成了一个不同的人。所以甘道夫就觉得，这事儿有蹊跷，你知道吗？但上面有铭文，当你把戒指拿出来扔进火里——因为普通的火烧不毁它，龙焰也烧不毁它。
Not even dragon fire? No, no, won't melt the ring. But when you put it like in the fire, it has an inscription, and it's written, I think is it an elfish guys? Okay, don't write me. I believe so. Thank you, Sam. When it's translated, the inscription says, and I did look this up, so I got it right,
连龙焰都不行？不，不，熔化不了这枚戒指。但当你把它放进火里时，上面会出现铭文，上面写着，我记得是精灵族的语言吗？好吧，别写信骂我。我想是的。谢谢你，山姆。当被翻译过来时，铭文写道——我特意查过，所以我没记错——
one ring to rule them all, one ring to find them, one ring to bring them all, and in the darkness, bind them. So the ring is essentially evil in nature, because it's an extension of Sauron, okay? And Sauron's like bad. This is bad, bad. But anyway, Frodo ultimately, you know, puts it in the lava lake thing, and it finally is destroyed. So lava is hotter than dragon fire?
一枚统御众戒，一枚寻觅众戒，一枚禁锢众戒，昏暗中束缚众戒。所以这枚戒指本质上是邪恶的，因为它是索伦的延伸，对吧？而索伦是个大坏蛋。这是彻头彻尾的大坏蛋。不管怎样，弗罗多最终，你知道的，把它扔进了岩浆湖里，它总算被销毁了。所以岩浆比龙焰温度更高？
Well, no, it had to go to Mount Doom specifically. It's a special lava. Because that's where Sauron made it. Oh, so it had to go back to where it came from. Right, sort of. Yeah, it could only sort of melt into its original source material. Yeah, I think so. Here's a cool thing, you know, can I just, before I know we're talking about the ring,
嗯，不是的，它必须去特定的末日火山。那是种特殊的岩浆。因为那是索伦打造它的地方。哦，所以它必须回到它诞生的原点。没错，差不多吧。对，它只能在它的原始源材料中融化。是的，我想是的。这里有个酷炫的点，你知道吗，我能插一句吗，虽然我知道我们在讨论戒指，
but at the end of this, are you going to tell me who the Lord of the Rings is? No, because it's, it's not one Lord, it's not one Lord. Sam? Okay, well, so originally they make a bunch of rings. Yes. There's like nine, nine for them, like men, some for the elves, some for the dwarves. Right. Then the one ring can rule them all.
但在这一切结束时，你能告诉我谁是《指环王》吗？不能，因为它不是一个单一的“君主”，不是一个君主。山姆？好吧，所以最初他们打造了一堆戒指。是的。大概有九枚，九枚给人类，一些给精灵，一些给矮人。对。然后至尊魔戒可以统治所有这些戒指。
That's what makes it so dangerous. Right. Yes, I mean, technically the Lord of all the rings would be Sauron, who made it. Well, because he made the one ring. Yes. If you were to get this ring, you would be the Lord of all the rings, but it will corrupt you and make you evil. It will corrupt you.
这就是它如此危险的原因。对。是的，我的意思是，从技术上讲，所有戒指的君主应该是打造它的索伦。好吧，因为他打造了至尊魔戒。对。如果你得到了这枚戒指，你就会成为所有戒指的君主，但它会腐蚀你，让你变得邪恶。它会腐蚀你。
That's what happens. It damages people. It damages people. So, it'll cripple you. Yeah, and the humans, the humans, it makes them like crazy. Yeah, it makes you insane and murderous and jealous and awful. I mean, that sounded good, actually, Sam. That was, you made that interesting.
事情就是这样。它会残害人。它会残害人。所以，它会让你残废。对，而且对人类，对人类来说，它会让他们发疯。对，它会让你变得精神失常、嗜杀成性、充满嫉妒且面目可憎。听起来还挺带劲的，其实，山姆。那是，你把这个讲得很有趣。
Oh my God! I'm sitting right here. I mean, I was like, while I was listening to that, I was like, huh, that sounds like really Shakespearean and sort of like maybe I'd like it. Maybe read the books. Maybe you'd like the books better than movies because you lose interest when things get fantastical and you could just flip a few pages past that. I don't know.
哦，天哪！我正坐在这儿呢。我的意思是，当我在听这些的时候，我心想，哼，听起来真有点莎士比亚的风格，也许我会喜欢它呢。也许你应该去读读原著。也许比起电影，你会更喜欢原著，因为当剧情变得光怪陆离时你就会失去兴趣，而看书的话你可以直接翻过那几页。我不知道。
Well, Michael is not moved by Dwight's Lord of the Rings logic. Yeah, he is. Like you. He's like, nah, I don't know. Okay, whatever. I mean, you know, he's going to sprint out of the office with the piece of paper. He's going to destroy it. I assumed he was going to run to the shredder?
好吧，迈克尔并没有被德怀特的《指环王》逻辑所打动。对，他才没有。就像你一样。他心想，才不呢，我才不管。好吧，随便吧。我的意思是，你知道的，他要拿着那张纸冲出办公室。他要毁掉它。我以为他是要跑到碎纸机那儿去？
Yeah. No. He runs all the way outside to his car, but shoot, he forgot his keys. Meanwhile, Dwight is chasing him, trying to get it from him. He gets his keys and then goes back out. And we know how elaborate it was to shoot that because all of those places, the stairwell, the hallway, they're all in different locations, in different buildings. So they would have to reset up and then make those guys run and then move and set up and
对。并没有。他一路狂奔跑到外面的车里，但糟了，他忘带钥匙了。与此同时，德怀特在后面追他，想从他手里抢回来。他拿到钥匙后又折了回去。我们都知道拍摄那一幕有多么繁琐，因为所有这些地方——楼梯间、走廊——都在不同的地点、不同的建筑里。所以他们必须重新布置现场，然后让这两个家伙跑起来，接着转移阵地，重新布景，
make those guys run. Right. They did such a good job of selling how tired they were because they only ever really had to run for short distances. Right, right. It was not actually all tied together. In the end, Dwight is like, Michael, you have to do this because if we don't do this, someone will do this to us.
再让这两个家伙跑起来。没错。他们非常成功地展现出了那种精疲力竭的状态，因为他们实际上每次只需要跑很短的距离。对，对。并不是真的全都连在一起拍的。最后，德怀特说：迈克尔，你必须这么做，因为如果我们不这么做，别人也会对我们这么做。
It will happen. Yeah. Did you see the piles of fake snow outside in the parking lot? I did. Nice touch, guys. Nice touch. Ultimately, Michael agrees to call Wallace and give him the Prince Paper client list. And he realizes he's not a shark.
这种事迟早会发生。对。你们看到停车场外面那一堆堆假雪了吗？看到了。干得漂亮，伙计们。干得漂亮。最终，迈克尔同意打电话给华莱士，把普林斯纸业的客户名单交给他。他意识到自己根本不是什么商业巨鳄。
No. It broke my heart that he gave him the list. I know. I was really rooting for Michael to destroy the list. There's going to be a callback to it. It's brutal. Brutal. Michael has a talking head.
不。他把名单交出去的那一刻，我的心都碎了。我知道。我本来一直很支持迈克尔毁掉那份名单的。剧集里后来还会有个回忆呼应。太残忍了。太残忍了。迈克尔有一个面对镜头的独白。
He shares it's a bittersweet moment. There was an alt talking head. I have to play it, guys. It's in deleted scenes. The last line of it made me spit out my iced tea as I was watching it. Okay. I've always been intrigued with the idea of ruling with an iron fist, and it is good for ruling, but you know what it's not good for?
他分享说这是一个苦乐参半的时刻。其实还有一个备选的独白。伙计们，我必须放出来给大家听听。它在删减片段里。其中的最后一句台词让我看的时候直接把冰茶给喷出来了。好吧。我一直对“用铁腕统治”这个概念很着迷，这招对统治管理确实挺管用的，但你知道它不适合用来做什么吗？
For caressing the face of a child, or making love to a woman with your hands, or thumb wrestling, or hanging out in the rain, or if you walk through a magnet store, you get covered in magnets. Oh, no. I'm done. No more iron fisting for me. He is so ridiculous. How did Steve get through that?
不适合用来抚摸孩子的脸庞，或者用双手跟女人做爱，或者掰手腕，或者在雨中闲逛，或者如果你不小心走进一家磁铁店，你浑身上下就会沾满磁铁。哦，不。我受够了。我再也不搞什么铁腕统治了。他太荒谬了。史蒂夫是怎么忍住不笑演完这一段的？
I don't know. How did he get through the line about walking through a magnet store? I don't know. All of it. It's so ridiculous. It made me laugh. I was like, everybody needs to hear this. How would they pick?
我不知道。他怎么能忍住不笑说出“走进一家磁铁店”这句台词的？我不知道。所有的台词都这样。太荒谬了。把我逗得哈哈大笑。我当时就想，所有人听了都会笑死。他们到底是怎么抉择的？
All of these are so good. How do they get in the editing room? They have to pick one. I don't know. We have to ask Greg about that sometime. I want to hear more about their process. Pick things. I mean, I know they would bring us in sometimes and ask our opinion, but it feels like every
这些片段都太棒了。他们怎么在剪辑室里做抉择的？他们必须选出一个。我不知道。我们以后得找个机会问问格雷格。我想多了解一下他们的制作流程。挑选这些东西。我的意思是，我知道他们有时会把我们叫去问我们的意见，但感觉每一集
episode they were having to make these decisions. Well, Michael ends up ultimately being the tiebreaker, so we do have a winner. Yes, he very casually says, she's hot. Yeah. And then our team wins. Our team won. And we had a lot of tangents in this, guys. We did.
他们都必须做这种艰难的决定。好吧，迈克尔最终成为了打破僵局的关键人物，所以我们确实选出了一个赢家。是的，他非常随意地说，她很性感。对。然后我们的团队获胜了。我们队赢了。而且伙计们，我们在这一集里扯了好多题外话。确实。
We hope you enjoyed it. This is just a window into our search history, guys. You're welcome. We will be back next week with Stress Relief, Part 1, and an epic cold open that I can't wait to talk about. Save Panda! I can't wait. We'll see you next week.
希望你们听得开心。这只是让大家窥探了一下我们的搜索历史，伙计们。不用谢。我们下周将带着《缓解压力（上）》回归，还有一段我迫不及待想聊聊的史诗级开场白。拯救熊猫！我等不及了。我们下周见。
See you next week. Thank you for listening to all of this. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
下周见。感谢收听所有这些内容。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码：Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。